viejo en el corazón del pantano es el
pueblo más francófono de luisiana el 40%
de los habitantes hablan francés como
rey ibex y croce quienes han vivido aquí
desde siempre hablamos francés pero no
el verdadero francés es un lenguaje
un día lector si un dialecto esa es la
palabra
es mucho más natural y fácil sale llega
naturalmente sin este dialecto lo
heredaron de sus padres los
descendientes de los acadia nos de
canadá pueblo francófono expulsado por
los ingleses en el siglo 18 y deportado
a luisiana rey crochet hace parte de 11
hermanos en su casa todo el mundo
hablaba francés entonces cuando ingresó
a la escuela el aprendizaje fue difícil
el peque marc y nieto de lo noble
que partía lejos
te aparece como imaginar
nunca has hablado inglés antes e
ingresas a la escuela y tratas de
entender lo que la profesora te pregunta
haciendo tu mejor esfuerzo para
responder
me dolía mucho porque se hablaban mal
inglés pensaban que no eras inteligente
patrón dijo
la inteligencia no tiene nada que ver
con el lenguaje que hablas
por conecta el exterior efe a ver cómo
el equipo hoy vice y rey van a la
iglesia como cada semana
guau hay mucha gente
pero este viernes de cuaresma es un poco
particular por primera vez desde hace 15
años la misa es en francés
la mayoría del sur de luisiana es
católico de hecho el estado está
dividido en capillas y no en condados
como el resto de eeuu una herencia de la
época en la que luisiana era francesa el
padre aprovecha su sermón para recordar
la importancia de las tradiciones
mucha gente abandono gran parte de
nuestra cultura francesa la cocina la
música nuestra forma de vivir
y por supuesto nuestra lengua francesa
en el evangelio de hoy
las palabras de dios nos motivan a no
olvidar la verdad que recibimos de
nuestros ancestros
con el paso del tiempo la cultura
estadounidense se impuso en todas
luisiana la prohibición del francés en
las escuelas entre 1921 y 1974 hizo que
la generación del rey no transmitiera la
lengua a sus hijos hoy sin embargo los
cantos resuenan como en el siglo pasado
[Música]
y sea la visión de luisiana tenemos una
historia francesa
y toda la vida la gente estuvo
condicionada por el francés francia y
luisiana están unidas por 300 años de
historia y relaciones económicas muy
importantes cada año 12.000 empleos son
creados por empresas francesas y francia
es el segundo inversionista extranjero
en el estado hay mil millones de
intercambios entre francia y luisiana en
especial en materia de energía y turismo
evidentemente los responsables louis ya
nos entendieron el interés del
bilingüismo hablábamos de la energía los
grandes grupos energéticos necesitan
empleados ejecutivos con movilidad es un
argumento que hacemos valer
y el desarrollo de la francofonía no
solamente es francia es canadá al norte
y toda áfrica francófona preservar la
lengua francesa es por lo tanto esencial
francia invierte en especial en la
educación enviando cada año cerca de 60
profesores de la educación nacional
escuelas de inmersión en francés en la
escuela primaria leblanc 45 alumnos de 4
a 6 años alternan entre clases en inglés
y clases en francés tres horas y media
al día cinco días a la semana
así
jose a
i
a muchos
h
[Música]
su profesora de francés viene de lyon
llegó a luisiana a principios de año en
virtud de los acuerdos francia luisiana
hoy les enseña los continentes
a sus alumnos de 1º de primaria perfecto
como ella algunos profesores también
vienen de canadá bélgica o áfrica para
enseñar francés en las escuelas luisiana
saber que tenemos eso en común y
compromete permite abrirse al otro es
nuestro punto en común nuestra fuerza y
en alguna medida une a la gente crea
puentes culturales y conduce a la
apertura hacia el otro
entonces la francofonía es importante
nuestra herencia nuestra cultura
hoy en día ya no se nace francófono pero
se convierte 5500 alumnos hacen parte de
programas de inmersión en francés y
llevan la antorcha de la francofonía
[Música]